what metrics are you measuring him by
why is he good at it
well hgg sees had a nice little run here
recently it's a private equity firm
based in Palo Alto they sort of
specialize in enterprise software deals
and they've had an IRR which is sort of
the way that most private equity firms
rate themselves of 66 percent as an
average over the past three years that's
a really big one one of the big deals
they did was a few years ago selling
this company Hybris to sa P they made
about a billion dollars on that deal and
Steve Young was very instrumental in
selling the company to sa P this is not
just an athlete that's sort of glad
hands shakes hands and is there for fun
he is a real deal guy and he's done a
great job for hgg C and Alex just
quickly you're doing connect the dots
for us because he specializes in
enterprise software the guy has a law
degree like how did how did he get there
from here
well he he played on the San Francisco
49ers so he grew up around a burgeoning
palo alto software culture and that's
where all the deals were as he started
to get into private equity in the early
2000s and he just grew to understand the
industry you know you're off your f year
you start to do these deals and like
anything else if you're around it a lot
you get good at it